it is a graphic retelling of what
happened on the set of rust when a gun
handed to alec baldwin killed the
cinematographer helena hutchins
this reconstruction made as part of the
case filed on behalf of her husband and
son and alleging wrongful death
in a lawsuit names
alec baldwin and others
who were responsible for the safety on
the set
and whose reckless behavior
in cost-cutting
led to the senseless and tragic death
of helena hutchins
the lawsuit alleges movie industry
standards over the use of firearms were
breached and highlights the concerns of
camera assistant lane looper over safety
he later told sky news this i've never
felt more unsafe
on set
or offset
the police investigation is still
focused on how a live round came to be
in that gun investigators say there was
complacency on set and haven't ruled out
a criminal prosecution
it's strange to go back to work i
haven't worked since
october 21st of last year
when um
this horrible thing happened on the set
of this film and alec baldwin's now
returned to making movies he's denied
responsibility for what happened to
helena hutchins the producers say safety
was always the priority but the search
for answers goes on greg milam sky news
los angeles